[Música]
[Aplausos]
viviendo en un área altamente urbanizada
es difícil encontrar espacios donde
podamos tener contacto con la naturaleza
gracias a la inusual duración de la
temporada de lluvias en un parque en el
justo en el centro de la ciudad empezó a
correr agua muy limpia y fresca en un
arroyo era un día muy caluroso y
decidimos llevar a nuestros dos hijos
pato y mateo a este parque al llegar
decidieron bueno sentarse al orilla del
agua y empezaron a lanzar piedras
obviamente la tentación fue muchísima se
quitaron los zapatos metieron los pies
se mojó un poco el pantalón y bueno no
quisimos arruinar el momento así que
fuera camisas y terminaron felices
remojados en el fresco arroyo en el
espacio había familias como nosotros
también con niños pequeños
justo cuando pato y mateo estaban dentro
del agua se creó como un momento mágico
todos los niños terminaron dentro del
agua como si el hecho de que mis hijos
estuvieran en el agua fuera un permiso
para hacer lo mismo se rompió el
paradigma de en medio de la ciudad no
nos metemos al agua
y se compartió un nuevo comportamiento
se creó un nuevo estatus jugó de aquí si
nos metemos al agua esta experiencia me
dejó pensando un poco y se dispararon
varios cuestionamientos primero porque
los seres humanos nos aferramos de una
manera tan fuerte los mismos
comportamientos
porque actuamos conforme al estatus jugo
de lo que sucede a nuestro alrededor
cómo afecta esto a nuestras comunidades
y podemos evolucionar como sociedad si
seguimos repitiendo los mismos
comportamientos
finalmente también es importante bueno
quienes se atreven a hacerlo de forma
diferente y cuantos valientes se
necesitan para empezar a transformar a
nuestro entorno
primero pensé que para empezar a
responder a todas estas preguntas era
importante entender muy bien cómo
funcionamos las personas de forma
individual los niños me parecen seres
fantásticos porque dentro de su espíritu
libre están casi libres de telarañas
paradigmas y normas pero los adultos no
somos iguales me puse investigar un poco
cómo funciona el cerebro de los adultos
se dice que los hábitos pueden ser
imperceptibles hasta que se vuelven tan
fuertes que no podemos romperlos
nuestro cerebro nos invita a actuar de
forma como en piloto automático si
pensamos en las rutinas que ejecutamos
día tras día tras día nos levantamos en
la mañana y casi siempre tenemos la
misma rutina al menos entre semana y
otra en los fines de semana pero no
tenemos ni siquiera que pensarlo no lo
hacemos sin esfuerzo muchas veces nos
unimos a nuestro coche salimos de
nuestra casa llegamos a nuestro lugar de
trabajo oa nuestra escuela y no pensamos
en todo el camino simplemente llegamos
esto a nuestro cerebro le gusta porque
porque esto nos hace ahorrar energía
nos hace ser eficientes nuestro cerebro
busca constantemente ahorrar energía
porque porque la verdad es que nuestro
cerebro gasta mucha energía
se dice que el cerebro puede gastar
hasta un 25 por ciento de toda nuestra
energía
en nuestro cerebro por lo tanto odia los
cambios sorpresa no le gustan los
cambios porque porque nos hacen
ineficientes
cuando nosotros empezamos a ejecutar un
comportamiento nuevo tiene que suceder
un cambio físico en nuestro cerebro los
comportamientos están basados en como
caminos de conexiones neuronales si yo
repito muchas veces un mismo
comportamiento se fortalece en esas
conexiones neuronales por eso mientras
más práctico por ejemplo tocar el piano
más fácil me es hacerlo
sin embargo las primeras veces que toco
el piano es sumamente incómodo es
sumamente difícil porque mi cerebro está
formando esas nuevas conexiones
entonces bueno como podemos hacer para
reconectar nuestro cerebro es algo
sumamente retador porque aparte tendemos
a evitar todo aquello que nos provoca
incomodidad es el journal of clinical
psychology ha descubierto que el 54 por
ciento de las personas que intentan
hacer algún cambio importante en su vida
abandona en este esfuerzo antes de seis
meses y además tristemente la persona
promedio intenta hacer el mismo cambio
en diez ocasiones distintas a lo largo
de su vida y en ninguna tiene éxito que
es lo que tenemos que hacer entonces
para lograr hacer estos cambios y bueno
los cambios dependen significativamente
de nuestra capacidad para crear y
ejecutar nuevos comportamientos es decir
tener como esa persistencia suficiente
superar esa incomodidad y ejecutarlos
tantas veces sea necesario como para que
se cree un cambio a nivel fisiológico y
ese nuevo comportamiento deje de ser
nuevo y por lo tanto forme ya parte de
nuestra zona de confort
ahora sí ya desde el punto de vista
individual suena algo retador imaginemos
lo desde el punto de vista social como
seres sociales que somos nuestras
decisiones también son influenciadas por
el contexto nuestras relaciones
interpersonales el medio ambiente físico
y eso me llevo a imaginar el poder de un
hábito pero multiplicado por una
comunidad
vamos a hablar de un problema muy
aparentemente muy simple que es el reto
de mantener los espacios públicos libres
de basura
les voy a contar la historia de juan
juan es un niño que le encanta el fútbol
y juan va con su papá a jugar fútbol
tres veces por semana a la cancha
municipal ellos tienen como su rutina el
camino a la cancha llegan a la tiendita
compran unas papitas un refresco van a
la cancha entrenan consumen sus
productos y al terminar arrojan la
basura a un área verde que está junto a
la cancha esto se ha repetido muchas
veces por muchos años de hecho juan ha
crecido un poco ya tiene 13 años ya no
va a la cancha con su papá ahora va con
sus amigos y siguen repitiendo
exactamente los mismos comportamientos
esta es una rutina tan repetida que
recordemos el cerebro ya formó una
conexión neuronal en el cerebro de de
juana y además esto es pues reforzado
por el entorno social de juana
el municipio
pues ha contribuido con pocos botes de
basura y muy ocasionalmente limpian el
área para juan el papá de juan los
amigos de juan y los papás de los amigos
de juan esto es culpa del gobierno y el
trabajo del gobierno limpiar el ajeno
ellos tienen la norma de aquí nosotros
podemos tirar la basura donde sea porque
aquí es trabajo del gobierno limpiar no
nuestro este fenómeno tiene varias
explicaciones desde el punto de vista
conductor
y el primer enfoque de la tragedia de
los comunes es un fenómeno que nos dice
que las personas tendemos a destruir o
acabar con los recursos compartidos
motivados por nuestros intereses
personales es una gran contradicción
porque a nivel racional sabemos que esto
no nos conviene ni a nivel individual ni
como comunidad pero lo seguimos haciendo
porque nuestros intereses personales son
más fuertes es un poco como pues si
todos lo hacen porque yo no
otro u otro fenómeno es bueno el
contexto social nosotros como seres
humanos estamos observando lo que sucede
a nuestro alrededor
observamos e interpretamos cuáles son
las normas de cada lugar
incluso inferimos por las condiciones
físicas del lugar en el presente
inferimos lo que pudo haber sucedido en
el pasado se ha comprobado que las
personas tenemos esta tendencia tan
fuerte de seguir a los demás que en
lugar de analizar muchas veces para
tomar decisiones tendemos a seguir a la
manada
en los lugares limpios la gente tiende a
tirar menos basura que en los lugares
sucios
eso es una condicionante se ha
encontrado que cuando hay no más de dos
piezas de basura tiradas entre el 80 y
el 90% de las personas no tira basura a
partir de la tercera pieza en adelante
el número de personas que tira basura se
puede llegar a cuadruplicar
quienes están involucrados en este
problema se dice que las personas
jóvenes tiran más basura cuando están
acompañados las personas mayores cuando
están solas los hombres se ensucian más
que las mujeres y la mayoría de los
fumadores tienden a tirar sus colillas
además tenemos como cuatro roles que
podemos jugar en este problema el
primero son los transformadores que son
aquellas personas con conciencia
ecológica que no sólo no tienen basuras
sino que además limpian la basura que
otros tiran tenemos a los no tiradores
que simplemente no tiran basura y
tenemos a los digamos a los complicados
que se les complica no tirar su basura
que se les complica deshacerse de su
propia basura porque pues los botes
están muy lejos o no hay basureros o
simplemente es problema de alguien más
no que el gobierno limpia para eso
pagamos impuestos
pero en todos los casos vemos que los
comportamientos son afectados por lo que
los demás están haciendo
roberts jardim y un importante psicólogo
social que ha estudiado muchísimo todos
los aspectos relacionados con el
fenómeno de la persuasión hizo algunos
experimentos en estacionamientos
públicos y fueron interesantes los
hallazgos fue muy determinante el que
las claves de lo que sucede en el
contexto determinan de gran manera los
comportamientos de las personas lo que
hicieron fue en un estacionamiento
llenaron todos los coches de volantes y
observaban que era lo que las personas
hacían al regresar a sus coches
si el estacionamiento estaba sucio era
más probable que las personas tiraban el
volante
si alguien veía a alguien más tirarse al
piso también era más probable que
tirarán el volante al piso si veía que
otra persona limpiaba un volante con un
rostro facial de rechazo nadie pero
nadie tiró basura si quitaban este
elemento de rechazo el 33 por ciento de
las personas tiraban su volante al piso
las personas somos muy sensibles ante lo
que percibimos como comportamientos
normales y tendemos a evitar aquellos
comportamientos que van a generar
rechazo por parte de los demás por eso
es importante cambiar y replantear la
forma en la que damos los mensajes en
lugar de decir aquí hay mucha gente que
tira basura
podemos decir algo como una sola persona
que tire basura arruina la belleza del
lugar es decir en lugar de normalizar el
comportamiento marginal hacerlo no bueno
no malo sino hacerlo como
que no corresponde a la norma es decir
aquí la mayoría no hace eso y si alguien
lo hace aquí la mayoría lo va a rechazar
bueno volvamos al caso de la cancha
municipal les cuento ahí entrena pato mi
hijo y siempre me ha frustrado mucho que
exista basura que esté sucia
y decidí reenfocar mi frustración y pues
ponerme a limpiar tenía que igual
esperar el entrenamiento pues
mi tiempo de una manera más productiva
mateo motivado por su aburrimiento ya
que él también tenía que esperar que el
hermano terminara de entrenar se me
acerqué me dice mamá te ayuda
a los 5 minutos ya que quería mejor esto
pues mucho trabajo mi mamá ya no hay que
limpiarlo
si quieres tú déjalo yo voy a seguir
limpiando entonces quiso ser solidario y
continuo pero a medida que su cansancio
subía su frustración también subía y me
empezaba a decir cosas como mamá porque
la gente tira tantas cosas que les
cuesta recoger su basura y además la
basura pequeña las colillas las tapitas
los papeles de chicles o son es la peor
basura es la más difícil de limpiar y
además la gente la tira porque pues creo
que no importa porque es pequeño y no se
ve pero es lo más explicado de limpiar
al terminar el entrenamiento nos subimos
al carro y yo estaba muy frustrada
porque yo esperaba que algunas personas
que estaban ahí también en la cancha
pues tuvieran alguna reacción un poco
positiva hacia lo que yo estaba haciendo
no sé
quizá contribuir o al menos quizás decir
bueno gracias pero no nada de esto no al
contrario más bien me ignoraban o me
veían como con extrañeza cuando nos
subimos al carro mateo le empieza a
contar a patos sobre esta experiencia y
fue un momento como de iluminación
porque me di cuenta que si bien yo
estaba frustrada de no haber logrado
transformar a nadie en el entorno pues
había tenido yo impacto en alguien
importantísimo no que era materia
a partir de eso mateo se volvió muy
entusiasmado con el tema y juntos
desarrollamos una estrategia como muy
sencilla para empezar a resolver este
problema punto número uno
si llegas a un lugar que está sucio
limpia cinco piezas no te va a costar
nada un minuto de tu tiempo cinco piezas
recordemos los ambientes sucios nos
invitan ensuciar más el gobierno no
puede sólo hay que ayudar se limpia
cinco piezas de basura dos confronta si
ves a alguien tirando la basura de aquí
no tiramos basura por favor levante
no le digas está mal tirar la basura no
aquí no tiramos basura marginar el
comportamiento aquí no hacemos eso y
expresar ese rechazo y finalmente invita
a 5 personas a hacer lo mismo no
empecemos como a multiplicar un poco
este esfuerzo
ahora la última pregunta no cuántos
valientes se necesita
y un centro de investigación el social
cognitive research de network center ha
hecho estudios tratando de descifrar
bueno cuál es el punto de quiebre en
donde una opinión pasa de ser una
opinión marginal solo de algunos a una
opinión de mayoría y descubro que si el
10% de un grupo está convencido de un
cambio y empieza a actuar conforme a ese
a esa nueva idea
entonces ese cambio social se vuelve
factible 10%
yo sé que es difícil y la verdad yo
quiero pensar que muy muy pocas personas
se levantan por la mañana pensando hoy
voy a arruinar el día de todos los que
me rodean o no sé hoy voy a hacer de mi
entorno el peor lugar el lugar más feo
posible quiero pensar que eso que así no
se da solamente creo que no se atreven a
lanzarse al agua porque van en piloto
automático que no se cuestionan cuál es
el impacto de sus comportamientos y si
viene el cambio da miedo un día pues lo
intentamos y no solo vemos que lo
logramos sino que los demás al ver
nuestro propio gozo quizás nos imiten y
se lancen al agua junto con nosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]